I want to look look up my name is Marc
Spellman and the global head of strategy
at accenture and one of the big debates
here we're having in Devil's is this
profession of them where are we going
with energy particularly this issue of
the mix between brilliant oil and
renewables and when you talk about
energy you have to make these we think
about what's happening on the demand
side and what's happening supply side on
the demand side the downturn has meant
that demand for its actually fallen by
about three percent although the
underlying assumption was a horrible
continue to rise but the thing everybody
needs to remember about any chettinad is
that when we look at the forecast the
ticky going out to the 20 30 the demand
for energy is just going to increase
massively particularly because of them
the increases in the middle classes in
countries like India and China and what
and what that means is that they want
energy for obviously domestic living but
they also needed for transport so the
demand for energy is not going to go
away the big thing on the supply side is
how do we find the right balance between
particular soil and gas nuclear
renewables and the key question that
we've got is the speed of we can even
vampire things like the new girls and
the key thing about renewables is that
what you actually is a flexible if you
like energy internet smart grid systems
to be able to bring those renewables on
stream and also to give customers more
flexibility into norm pattis so as we
look at the energy debate I don't think
it's all about oil and gas or renewables
it's about and we need to look at how we
optimize energy efficiency we managed me
to manage oil and gas carefully clearly
nuclear is going to be part of the mix
but critically need to ramp up
renewables we need more investment in
solar wind clean cold sequestration will
be critical but ultimately we also need
smart grids in order to be able to
facilitate the introduction of those new
renewables and scale into the vote of
the domestic and residential areas but
also to help a hank with just silat a
team
more effective use of energy and
matching supply and demand thanks very
much